strong people's skills can contribute to
a successful life and career those have
those qualities make an average of
29,000 dollars more than Americans with
average people skills they're also 42
percent happier with their lives
Vanessa van Edwards is the lead behavior
investigator at the research lab science
of people she uses experiments to help
even the most Awkward person make a
positive impression van edwards has
consulted for fortune 500 companies like
clean and clear American Express and
cyber security company Symantec she now
has a new book called captivate the
science of succeeding with people in it
she shares how to talk to anyone and be
the most memorable person in the room
Vanessa welcome to studio 57 all years
we are all ears
you call yourself a recovering awkward
person very much sure not no one here I
love knowing everyone all of us that are
good what does that mean and how did you
do it yes so I was that kid who was
terrified of recess would beg my
teachers not to go out on the playground
and you can sell goodness my mom is
gonna be like why did they use that
picture so that was me as a kid and as
an adult I always wondered is there a
way to study human behavior or their
formulas for charisma or blueprints for
personality and so I started a lab to
figure out if we could crack the code
from a science perspective when you
found out you questioned what did you
walk work there weren't experts in oh
that's good so yes so we found out that
there are patterns that we can study we
did an experiment actually with
conversation starters and I don't know
about you but I go to a lot of
networking events and the questions
everyone asks what do you do and how are
you and we found we actually asked
people to rate conversation starters and
look at quality of conversations we
found those were the lowest-ranking
conversations what works a lot better or
what I call sparkers this is when you
ask people to think for all the exciting
things in their life so you ask someone
working on anything exciting recently or
what was the highlight of your day in a
way you're asking the brain to look for
hits and not misses which is more
dopamine producing what's the best way
now charlie ignore how to do this
because they're pros what's the best way
to work a room oh yes so when I got to
events I'd always wonder what
do I stand who do I talk to so we
analyze we set up cameras around
networking events and followed people's
foot patterns and we found that super
connectors those really you know they
really know how to do it they get the
most cars stand in a specific spot and
every networking event and this is
called the social zone it's right as
people exit the bar so when people exit
the bar they kind of have their drink
and they're like who do I talk to and if
you are there social Saviour you're that
person there that's that sweet spot
where you make really high quality
conversations you know what I've never
learned if you are at a party and you're
talking to someone yes in a good
conversation yeah people who walk over
yeah as if there's no one else there and
start talking to you and interrupt what
do you yeah what do you do so that
actually is the best kind of bid for
belonging so what you want to do from a
nonverbal perspective is there's
research that shows that when we are
attuned to someone our toes angle
towards that person so if you don't want
someone interrupts you the best thing
you can do is actually close out your
body so if we wanted to talk we didn't
want Charlie to talk to us we could just
tuck the two of us angling our toes
towards the other so first its angle in
and if someone comes in the conversation
your best bet is to put your arm put
your hand on their arm so I see you ask
them to wait their turn and then say so
what brings you over here are you doing
we're here that's it that's kind of a
nice way ya know what are the other no
no's you want to avoid okay so biggest
trap add a networking event these are
the lowest quality of conversations most
people stand right at the beginning
right when you're taking off your coat
you're like kind of surveying the room
the problem is is in those conversations
we saw the most overhead gazing you know
when someone's kind of go oh yeah
looking to see so the best thing to do
is to try to avoid that start zone and
stand with an eye line of the host so if
the host can see you they're much more
likely to kind of grab you and say hey I
really want to introduce you to that
person and then you can kind of gesture
how do you know the host how did you
come here that's kind of as avoiding
that trap in the beginning and getting
to the sweet spot what about the you say
faking it until you make it is not worth
the effort yes so there's this really
interesting research I would think until
you make it is yeah it's basically
forcing yourself forcing yourself
the moment is that I've heard of it
before I'm Charlie Rose yes yes so when
you look at faking it
dr. Barbara Wilde found that there are
there's fake smiles right we all know
this the hi nice to see you never and
never never we never do that that we can
actually tell if someone's doing a fake
smile in fact that doesn't infect if is
positively more than a positive smile so
if you show up to events you don't
really like people can kind of catch
that emotion the different scene a fake
smile a normal smile well finally
Charlie has a secrets to success yes
really we did it a little bit okay
Vanessa van averts thank you captivate
is on sale now